hey
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it like the video guys a like
is the most important factor that
youtube uses to push out video so it is
really important that you like a like is
free also if you have watched two or
more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay
beef i'm tired of this i'm tired of
y'all i see the analytics there's like
50 percent of you that don't subscribe
beef with all you okay so i have a
couple announcements one
today we have our members only live
stream after after this so after this
show anyone that joins our memberships
can see our members only live stream me
ish and jess are going to you know take
questions and eat pizza with you guys so
yeah um sign up for memberships if you
want to see that it's only five bucks a
month also we have a new clips channel
we just hit 10k on the clips channel
so um
if you want to see if you don't want to
be notified every time we're live but
you just want to see clips turn on your
notifications subscribe to that channel
as well also my instagram is just dot
pearly thing so i think i just hit like
23 or 24k on there so yeah let's let's
let's hit 30. um also some things that
all the super chats today are going
towards a new studio we've been looking
at places right we've been looking at
some nice places you think you think
you'll live you'll manage there i don't
know i don't know i think we'll need
some more memberships and then it'll be
able to yeah so if you
if you want to see a really big studio
where we can bring in different types of
guests and maybe help other people start
their own channels
sign up for our memberships because it's
really important that we have a
consistent form of income
to count on so we can count on getting a
bigger place and therefore and reinvest
back into the channel
who's our member of the week jess our
member of the week is sentence okay
santiago
member of the week sentience every week
we have a member of the week um zentianz
has been here since day one yeah
literally like he was my first i
i wanted to quit when i first started
the show was horrible um because
no one is watching except zentia he he
was like one of my first big super chat
so he was he was really monumental and
like motivating me to keep going so i
was like i can actually you know keep
doing this shout out to sentence oh gee
yeah also um last thing if you want to
come on the show dm eddie if you're a
guy and you want to come on the best way
to come on is honestly to say that you
can bring girls because girls are harder
to recruit for um
so
yeah dm eddie tell them you have like
one or two girls and actually bring them
that's the best way to get on because we
always have a surplus of guys that want
to come on it's a shortage of girls um
and
yeah i think that's all my announcements
for now so why don't we go around
everyone say your name
your age um your relationship status
a fun fact about yourself
and any social media you want to plug
you can do that now so start with you oh
i'm on the spot i don't know if i'm back
um
hi my name is jesse praise i'm 23 years
old i'm a married man for anyone out
there he thinks i have a chance
and um
that's a fun fact where's crazy where's
your rank
[Laughter]
um
and i thought
i was there when the whale attacked
that's what i'll say that's that's my
that's my fun fact about myself
yeah they took down the whale attack
video on my channel so if you want to go
see it um put put your youtube channel
oh yeah so
my youtube is jesse praise uh my tech
talk is jesse praise on the school so go
there to to watch it but yeah
all right i am jessica i am 28 years old
and um a fun fact about me is
i can't use the one i used last time
cause i broke
um
a fun fact about me is a dream dog of
mine would be a golden retriever husky
mix siberian husky mix that is my dream
dogs if it if any of y'all
have that dog or know where i can find
it let me know should we get one in the
house next year no we already have it we
can get two no we need it too
she could use a friend
who's gonna take care of that friend
like the video if we should get a dog
next year no
put a thumbs down in the chat if we
should not um my
uh socials instagram
is
it's
girl underscore just and then my youtube
is your girl jess and someone actually
dm'd me for a new name pearl i can't
remember their name right now
oh what's your new instagram name yeah
someone gave me like uh
what's that what's that what name did
they give you i can't remember i'll have
to say it oh yeah don't say it because
if you haven't changed it you don't want
to know what it is i'll do it during the
members only live stream okay
go ahead okay uh hi my name is
hassan um in a relationship
a fun fact about me
uh
francesco toddy lil wayne
gwyneth paltrow and now we all got the
same birthday
september 27th
nice
hi everyone i'm martine i'm 30
30 years old
and um
i'm engaged
um
i get excited when people are can i use
that as my fun fact
recently
yeah relatively recently i got engaged
in december oh how do you do it
um we were in greece
tomorrow castle
hello everyone my name is david stevens
um
i am 42 years old so i think i'm the
oldest one in this room
uh i just turned 42 on the 3rd of august
recently
happy belated
thank you
and um my social media um you can google
search for that david barron stevens
like the title
b-a-r-o-n
um that's all my instagram youtube
soundcloud
um
reverbnation
all of it uh linkedin whatever
uh david baron stevens google
if you want to check it out i play music
happy to be here
hello my name is lee um 30 years old
signal single sorry
uh
fun facts
i play music and i rock climb
i do only fans and i'm a carpenter and i
do a bit of modelling as well
social media is
both tick tock and instagram is the same
lee dot sick l i dot sick
see ya
oh my gosh the chat right now
bring chesca will return jessica
jessica's a guest from a while ago guys
you
some you guys will bully guess sometimes
so well they don't want to come back we
don't appreciate that here we never we
never stand for bullying but don't worry
not you guys it'll be super fun
anyways anyways um okay so today's um
topic
is is protection a right or a privilege
so this topic was inspired
by the whale attack
yes so this video got taken off of my
channel um because you know sometimes
whales you know
blubber to the youtube gods
and make them take down videos even
though they consented and agreed to a
interview but you know whatever um
[Music]
so so anyways um
i was interviewing this girl and she
claimed that she could not walk home
alone at night without fearing men
and i said you're not entitled to
security in a big city and that it's
dangerous for anybody
so this set her
off and ended up getting my mic like
knocked out of my hand and then she just
threw a fan they were like screaming
what would they
ah
that's what they did
yeah i don't
oh
sorry if that was too loud and y'all do
don't the man's ego oh
massage the man's ego let's massage the
man's ego that's literally my favorite
part
anyways um so my question for the panel
today is is protection a right or a
privilege
and i would want everyone to go around
and say yes and you could say why
um
no because
right is it a writer a privilege oh um i
think it's a privilege okay um because
certain people don't get protected um if
they do certain things and to be honest
i don't think anyone deserves it you
know if you act like a dick and then
someone's a bang in the face i'm not
gonna protect you so you know
it's just it's one of them ones
privilege that some people get and some
people don't
yeah i would agree that it's a privilege
yeah it's a privilege you have to earn
it and by the decisions you make whether
it's the streets you walk down or
where you live whatever
yeah i would also say it is a privilege
because the way i see a writer right is
something that's automatic so
if i have to compel someone to do
something then it can't necessarily be a
right um so if someone is going to
protect me i'm in a privileged position
i think it's a privilege
um
i think when it comes down to it
whatever we're dealing with
nobody
can protect us better than ourselves
so if we're expecting someone else to
protect us we're abdicating our own
responsibility to protect ourselves
at that
i mean at that point
then we have to realize okay are we what
are we surrendering to other people are
we just going to live our life letting
someone else do our dirty work
so i think if we expect someone else to
protect us we're just being lazy honest
yeah i'm gonna agree as well i think
it's a privilege
you're not no one
owes you that no one owes you to be to
protect you and it's funny because you
said pearl in the uh when you went
interviewing people i think you
mentioned that
uh men get attacked as well there's like
a there's a
higher percentage of men being attacked
and back in my day in my day still my
day uh i'm still young
back when i was younger at least i was
in a band and were very extreme looks
like big hair and makeup and all that
stuff and i used to get bitten up all
the time we used to get followed around
so it's it's true like women think they
are the only ones who are vulnerable
they are the only ones who are being
chased by men and follow around but it's
not true i used to get bitten up all the
time so uh
take that
do you think it's a man's duty to
protect
his
girlfriend or wife
yes
girlfriend or wifey okay yeah you have
to you know that's
because one if you don't she's most
likely gonna leave you
and two
you know why would you want why would
you be okay with your girl or wife being
in danger if you can stop it from
happening or at least help the situation
come back to me come back to me
it's a hard one i definitely think so if
your woman's if you know if that's the
woman you picked and she's in your
corner you got to have her back
come with me so
yeah
yeah i think if you even look like
biologically like the way a man is built
he's he tends to be most of the time
stronger faster quicker
and so like just by that advantage he
has he sort of is in a better position
to protect his wife or
woman or even kids so
i would say that's a that's a
responsibility that men have women can
also protect themselves but
um a man should protect yeah
i believe that a man should protect his
wife
as the mother of his child
outside of that no
exactly that's what i was thinking
and that's and i might disagree with you
no no disrespect but i might disagree
with you on the fact that because he has
more physical ability that obligates him
to protect
because
what if the world's
reversed whether she's a female
bodybuilder and he's just a you know a
dude that works in an office
does she now have
that obligation to protect because she's
the one more in a position to physically
repel the attack
i think
it as a man
regardless of circumstances if this is
my woman this is the woman that prepares
my meals this is the woman that's taking
care of my child
i don't want anything to happen that
moment because i want to make sure that
my home is still there tomorrow so if
anybody comes and threatens her they got
a problem with me
but if she's just my girlfriend she's a
girl that i take you know we go drinks
we have some fun
but then doesn't a woman have to be your
girlfriend before becoming your wife so
what if she's someone you want to be
your wife and then what would you just
let her get beat up because she's not
your wife yet but it depends with
pearl's question
what was the original question
um what did i say is it a duty yeah is
it a duty to protect your wife or
girlfriend
as a girlfriend i wouldn't say it's a
duty like he
needs to i say he can in certain
situations he can but as a wife it's his
duty because he's in a now committed
relationship because he is married to
her but this is why i'm asking because
you know
it's like that question when people say
oh can you give wife benefits before
your wife right so the benefit of being
married is that it's my duty to protect
you right if i don't do it beforehand
i'm guessing you won't marry me when i'm
proposed
it's the duty word that it is like you
can you definitely can but if i put
myself in a situation where i am
i'm deserving of what comes to me it's
not your duty to protect me because i
put myself in that situation and in that
sense i agree with you i think the word
duty is what kind of gets me like i
think it's our default as men to be
protective but duty
i don't know
i don't think anyone should have duties
you know it's not
jobs like what's a woman's duty then i
mean i i think a woman has certain
duties in the relationship but you know
but i agree i agree with you i don't
disagree but it's the word duty that i
don't know if i if i would choose that
word that's all i agree with both of you
actually
um i believe that dating is practice for
marriage
okay
so
if i want that woman to marry me or want
to marry me i'm going to treat her in a
way
that gives her a preview of what it's
going to be like to be married to me so
if i just be like she
even if she's a total trash
right even if she gets really drunk and
just starts a fight with some guy at the
bar
and
if i had just met the girl i'd be like
okay see you later nice to meet you i'm
out
but if this was my woman
i've been here with her for like two
three years
you know we're maybe talking about
marriage
and
there's no way i i know her family i'm
responsible to her dad
okay
now this dumb girl i gotta pull her out
of here what am i gonna do
so then i'm thinking about it then i
feel the sense of duty
like i have a responsibility to not just
her but other people that want her to
get home okay even if she's being an
idiot so question for the panel why is
it okay for a woman to feel entitled to
be protected and provided for but it's
wrong for a man to feel entitled to sex
and intimacy
it's that word duty like is it your duty
to have sex with me as a wife or as a
partner yeah i think so if i've married
a dude yeah i would like that but i
don't know if it would be like a duty
like oh if you don't do that i i don't
know like it's just the word you
wouldn't you wouldn't expect it okay you
wouldn't want your wife to have sex with
you whenever you want it
yeah
but if look if she told me like look i'm
not feeling
100 today i would not be like no have
sex i mean yeah you can have an off day
at your job but your job is still
like you can have a day where you you're
off and you feel sick your boss might
say okay it's fine but it's still your
job exactly look if you kept doing it
and be like okay what's what's going on
here yeah are you not attracted to my
question you're not attracted to me are
you doing what what's the reason why
yeah but if she obviously
did it like for
a few days a week maybe
i don't see it as a duty
okay i don't know i feel like um like
our generation has like a negative
like connotation to the word duty so
sometimes when we hear duty we just kind
of hear it as like a burden or or you
like i don't actually want to do it
willingly but i feel like when i if you
reframe it sometimes duties like it's an
honor it's actually like okay like it's
your duty maybe like to serve your
country or to do something that you're
proud of and so that's kind of in that
context of a relationship i would frame
it that way but i would still disagree
with the point of whether a man is
intact
what was your point about from the man's
perspective sorry um the question i
asked was why is it okay for women to
feel entitled to be protected and
provided for but it's wrong for a man to
feel entitled to sex and intimacy
because well i mean maybe this room
mostly agrees but like in general when i
ask women this question typically it's
well what if the extreme scenario the
worst thing's ever happened to me ever
they go straight into
that their body is being objectified
yeah they only are wanted because of
their body when it's innate and men to
want that from a female but going back
to the question before if
a woman is it's her duty to
please a man sexually when does that
duty start since we're saying that man
has a duty to protect his girlfriend
from jump does a woman have the duty to
give her man the sexual pleasures from
jump since
that is
um i'm sorry but for me the way i see it
is right if you want me to be monogamous
with you you can't then just be like
okay i'll do this when i want you know
i'll only have sex with you and i want
because then you can't complain when if
the person cheats you can't okay if you
decide to not make it a duty you can't
complain when he cheats also like
imagine like
say you go out and she starts to fight
someone starts to fight with her you're
like well this time i don't exactly
exactly
why do you think male sexuality is so
stigmatized why must men put up with
female hormones being emotional and
crazy but women can't put up with male
hormones being horny
corny
i think people just it's it's what's
expected now you know as a man you're
meant to you're expected to be stoic or
to not show or to just be in control of
what you're doing and so if you fall
short in any sense it's somewhat seen
in a bad way um by society whereas with
women
sorry with women um people kind of
make allowances um
even if it's they're having a bad day or
was because of their period or whatever
you know we always have an excuse for it
and so it's okay so i think that's what
it is
i also think uh
[Music]
the um is like
i think
it's often
viewed that men are always in the mood
or most of the time we're in the mood
you know which
isn't the case like sometimes we've just
had a long day
you know we're not trying to like end
in a case where you know
you know your woman has like
laid the roses out and all of that stuff
and
you might not be
in a mood that she's in so you kind of
have to
but it's always perceived that there's
something wrong in the relationship
which just isn't the case because when
when it's the opposite you know when the
lady's like not in the mood you know
we're supposed to be understanding
um
but if you guys say no then the girls
then the girls say what's wrong what's
the problem you're cheating
fast
i i think men and women display
mental illness differently
i think especially when it comes to
hormones
and sometimes we ascribe hormonal
behavior as mental illness
you know we'll we'll see a woman that's
going through hormonal changes and we'll
call her crazy
we'll see a man that's going through
hormonal changes and we'll call it a
mid-life crisis
but that's just basically the change
that happens in their hormones they're
at a different stage in their life
and things are changing that they can't
control
and it
comes out it's in the crazy more
hyperbole than anything it's more just
you exaggerating and just saying you
know you're just acting wild it's not
necessarily saying they have mental
illness
i i think
yeah maybe sometimes i mean i know in my
own experience i i i i see your point
that that sometimes maybe we can use
words in the extreme and maybe we're
just
you know like halfway about it you're
crazy
not saying that she's gonna pull out a
knife and yeah do something
um although i have known some that might
um
but
but i guess my point is is you know
it's very uh in our society we we tend
to focus on
the struggles that women go through with
hormones and menopause and all that
but when
viewing that men from that same lens
and the changes they go through
and
um how our hormones affect our
decision-making
um i think often it's just labeled as
toxic
a man who's
corny
might um act a certain way so he's just
a dirty old man
when
that's probably how he's been acting for
the previous 30 40 years and how he's
probably gonna act for the next 20 years
that's just him being a man with
testosterone
in my opinion can i also it's kind of
like you said before as a man you're
supposed to
control your emotions and your feelings
and all that and your hormones and all
that
so it's not about them being horny it's
about them feeling you know what i mean
could i ask a question is that
okay like because obviously there's
mostly men here
how would you guys feel if like society
didn't sort of
curtail
a man's sexuality so if like we just
lived in a world where
every man's sexual desires was displayed
to the fullest would that be a healthy
would that be beneficial for society
i think it depends what you mean because
i don't think a lot of things would
there wouldn't be many successful men if
everyone was given into all of their um
you know desires sexual desires and you
know a lot of men would be in very
not very good situations if you know
they were just doing whatever they
wanted i think sexual discipline is a
good thing in a sense question for the
man have you ever tried nofap
eight years he's laughing
what's eight years what is his voluntary
selling no fap
sema retention yeah
it was very difficult
and it produced a lot of problems and i
made a lot of bad decisions huh it
caused problems for you yeah eight years
ago
no no no nothing at all no excuse me
okay well there was there were some
points here and there but the whole time
i became very religious um this was
around 2004 i had been working on cruise
ships for a few years
and that's pretty much like living in a
vegas hotel
no place for a 19 year old
so at 24 i was exhausted and i realized
that i had not matured one bit
i needed to go home and grow up
so
i went home
i grew up i quit drinking i quit smoking
i quit messing with girls
i got very religious
and went all in like i always do with
everything i'm not going to do it if
it's halfway did you realize i don't
know eight years is a long time but at
some point did you realize that when
when you were not releasing you we're
more productive
because you're probably thinking your
brain is thinking like okay look i'm not
releasing something is wrong
i need to release so i need to do more
things to impress or whatever i've heard
this before um i've heard that there's
some eastern disciplines that have this
and i've heard in the modern rp era some
guys are promoting this
i'm not going to knock it
because i feel that anything you can do
to promote self-control is going to help
you reach your goal period
however
i can't say that in my own personal
experience
that not
um
how do you say releasing my seed into
the wild
has
resulted directly in more production
i would say that focus
produces production
more than anything
and if you're using the no fab thing to
help you stay focused fine
but i don't see that as a direct
connection in my own experience it may
work for other people but in my own
experience when i started meditating
when i eliminated the things out of my
life that were wasting my time and not
helping me toward my goal
when i eliminated the people that were
in my life that were not helping me to
my goal and i started focusing on that
singular goal
that's what produced more of my my
progress than
you know just um
not coming yeah exactly i think because
i think a man should come regularly i
mean i subscribe to the whole thing if a
woman
you know
i i apologize if this uh gets
blocked but
i've heard this statement before
keep your man's balls empty and his
belly full and you'll never have to
worry about him coming home
but i think it's coming from home
there's something i said in the uk a lot
which is um you know
don't die from yash because guys are out
here doing certain things for
um just to get goals right and a lot of
times that can be
um detrimental to
what they want from one and one out of
life in terms of success uh you know
family and all those things right so i
think that's why
there's there can be a positive to the
whole no fap thing because it can focus
you if you're not trying to deal with um
that side of
life in terms of women and things like
that but i don't think it's even i mean
everything kind of comes down to women
really in the end for men because that's
why we do everything subconsciously but
i wouldn't say i personally and i'm sure
many others did it because they want to
get laid but it's just like in the back
of your head like i imagine i'm sure you
work out like you work out imagine you
know do more of those before the gym
you're probably not going to be as
energetic as
yeah
someone in the chat said you can have
prostate problems if you don't ejaculate
yeah i'm not saying dude all the time
that's going to be the hardest thing
ever
but to go back to your original question
i
personally think that society
would be a little bit worse if
all of
the men's sexual needs were met because
of women and i think that
right now
half of the men's needs aren't met and
women are still crazy if women knew that
this girl this girl this girl this girl
this girl is sleeping with the man that
they want oh they would go berserk
because all the men's needs are being
met by
umpteen girls and they actually know
about it oh it would be crazy so oh we
would we would kill each other yeah
it'd be great for men they would love it
to
have their needs met but it would be
substantially worse because women would
now know that
now we know there's multiple women for
every single guy just imagine if every
guy when they were born they're like
here's a list of five women you will
have throughout your whole life that you
can keep well and the problem is then it
would be a smaller percentage of men
having having all the women if sexuality
was just untapped it wouldn't be like
every guy got a girl it'd be a growing
like the number of virgins would male
virgins would get higher
and i guess that's like a really like
i've heard rollo talk about this where
that's a really big problem in societies
where if you have a large amount of
basically guys with no girls they get
angry
and then
i don't know bad stuff like bad stuff
happens i don't know what well it's kind
of like today right yeah yeah and today
we have
a group of men
who are dealing with hypersexual women
that are absolutely fine with having
multiple partners so that one guy can
have six or seven women at once
and the other five or six men
that should have a pair are just sitting
there
trying to not fat
interesting
so um i have a question for the men and
your experience
who do you know know more men that have
been abused by women or women that have
been abused by men just anecdotally no
data
just go around uh if you mean by abuse
you mean like being hit or yeah verbally
or yeah physically let's just let's
start physically i guess i know more men
have been hit by women yeah
um more men that have been hit by women
i don't know what the statistics are but
in my own life i have been hit by a
woman
attacked had to call the police
not that i couldn't fight back
but i chose to call the police instead
of do what i know my body could do to
preserve the situation and
prevent any arrests so i can say
firsthand in my own experience
that in my life
there have been more women attacking men
what was um did it come out of nowhere
no i saw it coming i was prepared
okay she had been out all night drinking
with her friends on a girls night out i
was home with a baby
yeah the baby didn't want to go to sleep
because she just likes to stay up and
kick it with me and listen to music
four in the morning she shows up
i've um
i've known more women
but i've noticed that a lot of them
might be lying also lived in sweden for
five years and they kind of just
to them sexual abuse for example is just
some guy looking at them you know and in
sweden like they say like it's it's like
the rape capital of europe
great and the reason why excuse me sorry
the reason why is because apparently
that's not me saying anything but
apparently a lot of them are lying about
it so i don't really know
i've had i've caught girls lying about
it though i've caught crows girls saying
that they've been beaten up and they
went to court and everything in terms of
the other guy was an incense so
you never know
also us guys we don't happens we don't
we tend not to address it as much like
we do yeah we'll be embarrassed about it
yeah it's it's
you know i've been in one situation it's
a while ago but
i didn't talk about it for years
and then someone was like i don't even
know that happened we don't
you know because
we know if
you know the authorities get involved
we often look like the bad guy
you know even
because the woman could be 100 percent
in pop we look like the bad guy so can i
just question though because
oh sorry it's me
because you know
i've never been hit by a girl and
for me the moment even looks like she
might
the moment he even looks like she might
i'd be out there because i don't want to
put myself in a position where i feel
the need to hit a girl because i know it
won't end well so
did you guys stay in those situations or
did you
leave
because i don't i don't see how it can
that can end well for anyone
bro it was a rap 30 seconds later it was
over after that like
i mean once all the
emotions calm down you know there's
apologies or whatever like whatever the
issue is like
there's no it doesn't end well if it
starts with you know throwing fists you
feel me so that's that's the way that i
saw it
so you know those apologies after that
but i was kind of like plus i'd sort of
seen it
before with other people so i was i was
like that never ends well and i knew
even not fully understanding what i
wanted for me in a relationship i knew
that for sure that wasn't for me so i
was out was that a thing
was there was there like a switch
because i've always i've heard from guys
where like the girls will be super nice
and then they get either a kid or a
commitment or whatever they wanted
there's just like a switch in them and
they go crazy yeah well it
what happened at that time was um
we went from being a couple to like
living together
so like
and it was
you know we had disagreements before so
like the it was it was gradual
escalation
you know and then when it goes to like
goes to fists you're kind of like what
i know you do not just
you know it's little things like
you know like they take a swing or they
throw something or like that's how it
kind of starts so it's like little
things yeah and you're kind of like that
was weird and you're kind of like yeah
you ain't gonna do nothing
it's not a
[Music]
because i've noticed that a lot with
people from the us i mean you're all
from the us
you know it's it's a funny thing because
we with men we have that knowledge that
with any one of us if it was just men of
the room
we show a level a minimum level of
respect because we know that any one of
these guys could knock us flat
even if he's smaller than us even if he
looks dirty and like he ain't put
together he could probably knock us flat
if he knew how to fight we don't know so
we respect with women
that
threat
is reduced
and there are women out there that will
take advantage of this fact
they will attack a man knowing that his
guard is down
and that he won't fight back especially
if he's a good guy
yeah can i disagree with you
of course please do let's spice this up
um
i would agree with you only if like
statistically
um
the statistics show that the level of
let's say dv
um in
um same-sex relationships so men and men
is just as high if not higher actually
so how how do you account for women
women and women have the highest dv
rates
and it's actually one-sided abuse more
women do it than men
but but men and men is higher than um
men and women no women and women is the
highest oh yeah i'm not disputing yeah
but men and men is still higher than men
and women
no i don't think oh you're saying men
and men is higher than men
so it goes women and women than men and
men yes and then um heterosexual
relationships so his point was that men
would um if men in a room had a
disagreement right and correct me if i'm
wrong um they would see that okay maybe
this guy is a bit bigger than me so they
wouldn't confront it in that way whereas
women are given a pass so they know that
the man isn't gonna necessarily hit them
i think is more so heterosexual
heterosexual yeah exactly now we're
talking about
men in a room that don't know each other
assuming that everyone is a heterosexual
male
if
just like tonight i came in i didn't
meet everybody i i just met everybody
tonight
so i don't know what everybody's sexual
orientation is
i don't know what everybody's fighting
level is
i don't know if if i was to have you
know three of these cups and start
acting a fool
i don't know which one of y'all is going
to take me out
so i i have to maintain a level of of
appropriateness
that with a woman
even if we were romantically involved
right if if i was with a dude
romantically
i would already know what his level of
fight is so i would know how far i could
take it with him but if i'd never if i
just walked into a room and i didn't
know who was in there i walk into a bar
i see those dudes at the bar i don't
know which one of those is going to be
the challenge for me
so i have to be careful and it's the
same with me when i go out interviewing
people like the women are way more
reckless whale attacks
because like if i'm with a guy
and a girl starts acting crazy he's just
gonna pull her aside and tell her to
stop but if it's another dude like you
might get punched
like if another dude's acting aggressive
towards me there's gonna be a group of
guys that just start like coming to
defend me because it's just like guys
having an innate you know but even when
we were doing interviews um that group
would go why look at me like that man
just i didn't do anything okay
you didn't knew enough and i'm kidding
i got the content why would you let him
i got us the content that's what matters
when we were going up to that group of
girls yeah one of them wanted to be
interviewed but the other one didn't um
what's it called when the girl started
grabbing me putting hands on me right
yeah
i would never do that to a girl because
i kind of know that you know it's just a
bit it's a bit techy if you know someone
sees that but i think in society there's
not as much of a stigma on women putting
their hands on men in generally and so a
lot of women are a lot more
okay with doing it even if the exact
same
um um movement or you know action from a
man would be seen as well what are you
doing like that's that's wrong so i
think that's also another thing there's
no there's not as much stigma
yeah because modern women don't have
consequences for bad behavior because
they
i mean
do you hear about that teacher in the
u.s
she slept with a 13 year old and got 60
days in jail now she's out isn't that a
movie also with adam sandler
and
even that only that only fan's model
that killed her boyfriend
she she was out of jail because she's a
pretty girl
like they didn't even keep her for a
week and she's
but it's like men know that there's
always going to be a consequence like if
they hit a girl they are going to jail
there's no if ands or buts but if a girl
does it to a guy
she'll get a slap on the wrist
i'll put her in perspective for y'all i
have um from that night i was describing
don't need to go into all the detail
i have a shirt that was torn off of me
right by this woman
in this country
the uk um
when making allegations of assault
you have a six-month statute of
limitations never heard of that i'm from
the states it's not like that
here in this country i got a letter
from
the people who investigate the constable
area or whatever it's called here in
this country forgive me all the operates
they sent me a letter that said we are
not going to investigate because it is
outside of the statute of limitations of
six months
i got the photo from the day of with my
shirt torn off
my baby was in my hands i was holding
her like this protecting her from this
woman
right
and nothing's going to happen
ever
wow
i'm sorry but some women are way too
comfortable touching men or getting
rowdy men even
the time i did in street interviews
before i did one of pearl um there was a
group of girls we interviewed and um
like these two guys came up to us and
trying to sell them like balloons and
stuff right and one girl said no and the
other one kind of said it in a rude way
so then obviously the guy started
getting agitated because he's like don't
get rude
and then she's trying to match his
energy and i'm saying to the guy bro
it's not worth it just leave it like
she's
she's waved let's calm and he he says to
me oh you know what if you weren't here
i would have banged in the face so he
starts walking away in it and then the
goal is still acting up like no no come
back come on i'm just gonna
[ __ ] like
relax
i'm gonna try to die today
but he comes back and obviously starts
beefing at this point i'm just like i'm
good i'm gone i did my part and
obviously he ended up
like dashing something on her face but
he could have he could have destroyed
her like he could have done whatever she
was getting way too comfortable
i think some women don't have that
understanding or just plain common sense
that
men are naturally stronger no matter if
they look scrawny no matter what
if you get punched by the right one you
could die and females don't understand
that they not all females but certain
females feel like they have to
assert themselves or feel like they have
to be assertive and let their place be
known like no you disrespect me the
second third i can put my hands on you
because you did xyz i think they do i
think the reason sometimes the reason
why
they do that is that because they know
they might get a reaction and they're
going to win the case whatever the case
is you know what i mean because they're
like oh i know you're stronger than me
i know you can hurt me so as soon as you
touch me i win but that's assuming you
survive yeah well yeah
yeah they know they're gonna survive
with the they know in this world the the
the rules are created the world that
they live in i mean
you know let's get it straight this is a
matriarchy
there is no patriarchy in this country
this is a matriarchy but what i mean is
that she's assuming that the guy will
let her survive to you know go
absolutely she's assuming and what if he
doesn't what's going to happen then
you can't you can't bet on that because
some guys are crazy and sometimes
sometimes you're going to have that
barrier and they're going to snap
and that's what we as men deal with
every day you never know if that guy
that you're messing with is just gonna
snap on you maybe he was crazy maybe he
was drunk
and you're gonna have to deal with the
consequences she's not thinking along
those lines she's thinking oh let me get
something for the video what do you
think of women that get in between guys
when they're fighting that's the dumbest
thing that's the dumbest thing it never
ends well have a good story about that
time so when i first came to england um
i lived in croydon and obviously croydon
isn't exactly nice now but it was even
worse back then so um me and my siblings
were walking back from school
and these two guys were fighting
one girl from the local secondary school
tried to get involved and try to get in
between the two guys
i turn around
um to look at my sister turn back around
the girl's ear is in her hand and
there's blood everywhere
yeah because obviously one of the guys
got a knife out and tried to do
whatever and
she ended up with half a hair cut off
girls that do that i did not know what
they're doing but hey that can't be me
it could never be me
have you seen that what's that porn
star's name uh very big excuse me
cornstar
a very big cornstarch
that her fiance or husband was a some
sort of fighter and he beat the crap out
of her he's in jail now for life
wow uh what's that cornstar's name
anyway you don't know that case no well
it's a big case it doesn't surprise me
yeah he's been like
a mixed martial artist or something yeah
like a professional fighter or something
and beat the crap out of her sounds like
he had a lot of attention to get off his
chest i think he she
was filming
she was filming something and then they
were doing it at her place and then he
found them together you know he knew she
was a corn star uh but he got jealous i
don't know i don't know what happened
okay yeah don't you guys feel like um
will smith got off lightly for putting
his hand on the mat yeah yeah so
it's not just women that sort of get
away with that what if what if chris was
a woman did you think he would have got
in the way of it
no
[Music]
violence on men the same way they regard
violence on women
men are seen as expendable in society
where women women are seen as more
valuable than men
that's why they have been do all the
hard jobs
that's why that's why women get slapped
on the wrist for everything they could
sleep with a minor they get out of it
they can
hit a man and get out of it whenever
it's against men like they just get out
of it
you know i used to get hit on by this
colleague of mine
and i told people i told my my singing
teacher and she's like oh i bet you love
it and every time every time we tell
someone like come on man it's fine i bet
you love the attention
nah not really yeah i've had a similar
experience where i got essayed by this
girl
and like she
obviously i i didn't want to hit her
because i was just like you know
get off me but i don't want to hit her
or anything because i'm not trying to go
through something you'd be in trouble
exactly and then i remember i was
telling this guy at work and he was like
nah man you must have loved it i was
like
are you done
but that's the thing it's just seen as
like can i just add something to that
actually because i think a lot of the
time what tends to happen is when we
have these experiences where
men get essayed right and other men go
oh bet you loved it it's probably
because they haven't had any sexual
interactivity and so
they're projecting
what they would have felt in that
situation because they haven't been
touched in a while yeah i guess i
completely agree obviously
you know
i wasn't in any danger like i wasn't
gonna be hurt or die or anything but
it's not a good situation to be in a
sort of position especially when you
don't want to be in that position but
yeah we're just expected to you know
take on the channel we'll just enjoy it
and take it
anecdotally how common do you guys think
um
essay is from women to men
and just anecdotally no no
no no not no numbers just in your
personal experience is that something
that you know to be common i mean for me
personally um it's happened a lot whilst
it was at uni and a lot of my friends
happened to them too
um
but i don't know about in
general you know
i guess it depends on how you define it
um yeah
if you would uh call it unwanted sexual
advances i'm sorry uh is that one of
those terms i need to know you could say
that that's fine this time unwanted
advances
um
i think
anyone who is of an age to where they're
attractive are going to get advances
some of them are going to be from people
you want some of them people you don't
want
men and women both
um nobody wants to be you know
approached by them
and they come up hey come on come over
my house no nobody wants it
but you don't want whale sightings
you know unless you're into whales
you know
whales wealthy loving too
but uh you know yeah and exactly and
some sometimes it's gonna you know
you're not gonna feel it and
no means no
right and that's not just a woman thing
that no means no men need to set their
boundaries too that's part of what makes
us men we set our boundaries and if
anybody crosses it you're going to feel
the consequences period i think what
happens more often is that women it's
not really their weapon they make rumors
though that's what i've noticed they
make a lot of rumors girls like do that
like grape rumors accusations and all
that stuff that happens very very often
it's just not ignorant
no
that's actually
i've heard so many horror stories from
girls i just don't believe them all
there's too many girls that like come
like that when i'm interviewing will say
this all this stuff happened to them the
worst horror story ever but they don't
press charges yes if this happened why
wouldn't you press charges that doesn't
make sense unless you think you don't
have evidence and maybe you're not
telling the truth like i know i know
it's difficult to do but like
it just doesn't
it's too i hear it too much and i don't
think that many men are out there just
graping everybody doesn't make sense
like there's something they're not
adding there's some detail that's
important to the story
i don't think anybody that's been a
victim
that doesn't want a person to victimize
them to pay
i think there are some cases where
a victim can be in a situation is afraid
of the consequence by bringing that to
the attention maybe they still live in
the home
of their abuser
so maybe they're afraid if i complain to
the police tomorrow i'm getting beat
there's that but that's still the small
ask every one of those people if they
want that person to be thrown in prison
and they're going to say yes i think the
majority of these people that personally
that
make the accusation
and have no intention of fulfilling are
either telling a story that they heard a
story that they saw on tv a story they
wished happened so they could have
something to talk about
i i do think like the way like society
is now i feel like it is the best of
like worse options so obviously it's not
great because there are women that you
know exaggerate and lie and sort of the
power is with the women but i've lived
like because i went to secondary school
in nigeria and like in nigeria it's like
a completely different culture i can't
say don't come for me i can't say how it
is right now
um but when i was there like you'd be
hara i would be harassed constantly by
men and the thing is as well in that
society women are blamed so like it
instead of actually seeing why has this
man done this they're going to say but
what were you wearing what were you
doing to to bring that on and so like
it's a lot worse in those kind of
societies where i can really appreciate
here where even though yes it's never
there's never going to be complete
equality so even though there are um
it can be really terrible for men but at
the same time i do feel like this is the
best best of both worlds do you think do
you think women should be heavily
questioned though if they're accusing
someone of something that serious where
they should be questioned on everything
it's not saying like you deserve it but
it's maybe questioning the person's
credibility
i think on a personal one-to-one level
um
i wouldn't necessarily have any heavily
questioned like we're talking about the
law in terms of yeah if it's a public
thing and it's going to court yes i
think it's innocent until proven guilty
so um but if if someone came to you
personally i wouldn't go about oh are
you sure this happened i think you
should just take it on board and try and
um you know take it to the right
authorities
i think i think when you when you say
that you know
i understand what you're saying but
don't you think you're saying it's
better this way because it suits you so
i've been in a situation where someone
said oh he's done this but then when you
question a bit you find out actually no
nothing none of that happened and she
just said that because she didn't want
to feel as though she was a
you know three or four or whatever right
so don't you think that what you're
saying
is is better is just a situation that
benefits you and actually in a society
where we question people when they make
accusations where the consequences of
those
accusations being true are very
very deep consequences negative
consequences isn't it better that we
you know look into it and see okay is
this true
yeah to answer your second question yes
it is better to obviously investigate
and i feel like that's where this is
just like a backlash obviously like an
overcorrection of the things that went
wrong in the past
however because i've like experienced
both i won't necessarily say it's better
just because i'm a woman obviously that
is a factor to it but i also feel like
it's just not um productive for society
for women to be like harassed constantly
by men like it just i've had even
situations where a bus driver has
followed me like in the bus with people
in the bus i don't know
i don't know that nigerian could be
their uncles can be different but like i
don't what i mean is you know the people
that question you when you come to them
and tell them yeah isn't it better to
live in a society where people are
questioned because the consequences are
that because even if it's just in
personal life like that's character
assassination
so men every day can have their
character assassinated around campus and
in their communities and the women
aren't questioned at all
yeah exactly like i mean if i was a
woman and some some a man went to court
for something like he was accused for
something even if he was if he came out
innocent i would not be with him if i
was an employer i would not hire him
because you never know
that person's character and personality
but not personality yeah
that person is pretty much rude for me
so um question
do women have a right to be afraid of
men when eighty percent of violent crime
is done by men
i think so sorry what's the question do
women have a right to be afraid of men
because eighty percent of violent crime
is done by men
i think they'd be smart to be um scared
of men because i know for facts about
the daughter right now i i tell her be
careful when you're walking on the
streets for a random event you know i
think it's better better to be you know
safe than sorry
um
but obviously most
it's when people say that they feel
unsafe feeling unsafe and actually being
unsafe for two different things because
men tend to be the ones that
are the victims of violent crime the
most
so it's it's a balance what about you
guys
i would say be aware
um
that
the stat is what it is but i wouldn't
say
like
every day oh as soon as you walk out
your door 80 of men are dangerous and
walk in that fear because you're not
going you're gonna assume every man is
going to
attack you or do something to you
because you have that stat like be aware
but still like
live your life and
act accordingly don't be stupid and
naive and go out at night and go down a
dark alleyway and put yourself into a
position for something to happen just
but just be aware that's what i would
say
okay yeah i think that um
we're creatures of routine so if you're
going through the same areas same
neighborhoods like going from work or
wherever it is that you're going over
time you're gonna feel safe i mean
you're not you know if you don't if
you're doing though keeping it simple in
that sense like even me
moving to the aki to get used to like
you know how like the street lights
don't light up the sidewalk like the
pavement
you know so i'll be walking in the
street because they're better lit
because i don't know who's like lurking
in the dark
under so i think
we all should just put ourselves in
safer situations and we're less likely
to be you know worried male or female so
yeah i think the problem is like there's
not too much of a distinction between
what it is to be a man and what it is to
be a woman and so that has sort of like
erased women's fear because society is
just telling us like we're exactly the
same and we're not so i think that fear
is actually very beneficial for women
and um so you you do think that we
should be afraid of men like if to some
extent i'm just clarifying yes yes
because they're different okay yeah what
about you guys
i think um
i think it's a difference between men
and women because men will always be
afraid of other men
we may not fear men
but we recognize the threat
always
so my job as a father of a daughter is
to teach her
that she needs to cultivate this type of
awareness it's not a fear
it's an awareness it's an awareness that
at any moment when i'm dealing with a
man
if things go sideways i could get very
physically damaged
and just
accepting that and then operating from
that and and having the mental health in
order to not allow it to turn into
paranoia
and keep it in
something that produces protection
self-protection and not like just
freaking out
yeah same i think they need to be aware
um not fear
aware for sure but the thing is like
women menstrual can be the scariest
thing to a woman but it can also be the
um
what's the opposite of scary
fuzzy
yeah
yeah they can protect women as well
um
and i wanted to ask did do your parents
ladies did do your parents ever tell you
to fear men
no no
no no okay so so
just this follow-up question
how is that different than fearing
certain races because of statistical
data
damn
i didn't necessarily think that's a bad
thing to be honest but that's just me so
so if we flip this conversation and
insert it as a race yeah
you'd think that's fine i don't
necessarily think it's a bad thing but
okay
this is spicy i like it interesting i
think one can be racist
and or sexist and not be both
so i think it's possible to understand
the dangers of a male versus female and
not be racist
i also think that some people could say
do you mean sexist or sorry sorry
um so i also think that some people
could be worried about other races
having
relations with their women like is often
the argument that gets put out there
because of their build because of their
physique whatever
and
maybe there's a point to that i mean
there's
people from asia tend to be smaller and
billed people from scandinavia tend to
be tolerant build if you've got a
scandinavian dude walking around asia
yeah most of the guys over there are
going to be a little worried
what do you think
yeah that's why like when you ask the
question i i said it's down to biology
for the male and the female with the
race one i just personally can't see it
down to biology it could hypothetically
be because you could say one one group
is taller and more like and stronger
where one is weaker and smaller
it's like asian yeah yeah
and obviously in certain parts of
america the i'm guessing this that show
that um black men are incarcerated more
for violent crimes and agentmen but
their violent crimes are against other
black men they're not they're not
against like but that's not what what is
that that is the point we're not talking
about who said it
no the point so i'm saying like like i'm
not i'm it could be a black person that
says that too she's talking about like
like anybody like overarching like
saying like oh
i saw a black person rob a corner store
all black people rob corner story the
same way we're kind of doing that with
men so it doesn't matter who the crime
is against like the point is when
there's statistical differences is it
okay to make an assumption about a group
and so when you said yes when it was for
men but when we changed it to race you
said no
and and so i'm at why yeah i think like
if the if the statistic is you have to
analyze the statistic like very
carefully and like with the whole
situation in america like with the black
on black crime that's it's it's more
within their own race so someone else
who is outside of that race saying oh
but
but you keep you keep moving it yeah
because he could say the same thing yeah
i can make the exact same oh yeah yeah i
don't if you within your own race um
then yeah that makes sense what's the
difference between me saying him saying
if the stat still shows the same thing
because it doesn't show the same thing
that the the stats is showing the crime
is within their own race but we're not
we're not talking about
crime within
a community within we're talking about
what is the difference between
saying you should be afraid of men
because 80 percent of men are scary and
saying okay
80 percent of black people rob corner
stores 80 percent of white people
rob a
a
another type of store
should you categorize like okay i'm not
going to go to a corner store because i
know that black people rob those i'm not
going to go to this type of store
because i know why people are off those
xyz and not saying like the crime within
the community is
it's we're talking about over like
clumping people because we know that
these group of people do that and say
like is it the same because you're
basically saying well it's like the same
race that owns the store so but that
like that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about the the difference
in the crime stat
i guess it's the difference between
sexism and racism yeah right
but it's just it's just interesting how
like one like it we can almost openly
say one and nobody bats an eye but if we
flipped it with race everyone would
i think everything would admit to it
really if if nobody's looking if the
cameras aren't on and we're talking with
just just our people we say stuff like
that all the time to each other but we
just won't admit it in public i think so
that's something that like if someone is
afraid if someone had like a trauma
say i had a trauma like say i guess you
used to get beaten up by black people
all the time and i have a trauma and
every time i see a black person i'm
afraid would you blame me for it
i'm not saying
it's not
but women can openly do that yeah and
and i think if it was reversed like no i
think people would call you right yeah
they would call you a racist
but women openly i all the time like
this is oh god all the time when i'm
interviewing people on the streets
they'll say well i like women always
have a horror story that they bring up
like to the point i i it just doesn't
seem credible because everyone has one
yeah but they can openly do that and
it's socially acceptable it's like when
um again with the whale attack
when the lady was saying it's not all
men it's not all men but i don't know
whether it is so it is all men right no
thomas
not all men right she said no oh man oh
man she yes so she initially she was
saying it's not as in she was copying
what um uh
essentially not all men not all men but
i don't know if it is if he's you know
he doesn't wear a shirt saying he's not
going to grate me so it is because of
that yeah like what if we switched yeah
exactly and i i remember i was trying to
answer the question that you know
there's in throughout history there was
stuff that white women did to black men
and so is it okay for me to
then carry on going through life and
saying oh all white women do this and
the point i was trying to make her was
that just because it's happened before
doesn't mean i can assume that she's
going to do it to me too but we didn't
get to that because you got angry but
yeah the thing is you can't really blame
someone with trauma i understand it
might be racist you can be aware of it
you can go to therapy and whatever but
in the end you can't
blame them for it okay for example when
i was living in greece when i was young
i was dressing up and all that with
makeup and all that
i i had like a lot of albanians beating
the crap out of me and for a very long
time i just i was
yeah i was very
aware
every time i would meet some albanian
guy because i would think okay he's
going to beat me out because he's from
that same
country
don't get wrong i think i think it does
make sense for you to have that feeling
but what i'm saying the point which i
guess paul is trying to make is that you
know
we
people wouldn't openly say that or
openly say that they tend to
discriminate or have a certain idea of
races um based on things that have
happened or based on statistics but yeah
women can come here and say menotrash
menindees men are that and
it's seen as oh well she's experienced
it and so it's fine yeah why do you
think it's okay for women to be sexist
but not racist
well it's not just women like the
question
it's more like how women could be sexist
and black and black people can be racist
in in it's i think that's a better
equivalent what do you say so i think
it's a better equivalence is like how
women can be
allowed to be sexist the same way black
people allow to be racist
that's another conversation no no
because that's a different conversation
now the question is why is it okay for
women to be sexist and not racist
because
it's it's just
common right it's so it's so like
misandry is so common i hear it every
day but nobody bats an eye
but if but if we switched it to race
they would so is it sexist then the
example you gave of
basically telling a woman you know a man
is different from you you should have
some level of genuine fear like you
can't just walk into a man's house that
you don't know off nowhere and think
he's just another girl you can't treat a
man like a woman right but i'm saying
you shouldn't walk into anyone's house
you don't know
i'm not i'm not walking into whales
houses
why are you is this a common
problem did your parents have to tell
you that
no some girls literally felt like i
personally have seen some girls feel too
comfortable around men and i'm just like
hoes
[Music]
i don't like to use that word
jezebels
there you go
yeah some girls just feel very confident
and i feel like it just comes from a
lack of or even hitting a man it comes
from a lack of fear of that man because
like you have no
fear within you that knows that oh he's
different if he slaps me once i could
die like you literally don't have that
in you and i think that i wouldn't say
teaching someone to
in quote unquote have this kind of fear
i'm not saying be afraid like never talk
to men again but have a fear of
genuinely he can take my life if he
wanted to
um i don't think that's wrong i don't
think that's sexist it's common sense
it's not even
it's common sense
a man has testosterone testosterone
makes you strong
and if someone has more testosterone you
then
they're going to be stronger than you
you shouldn't put yourself in that
situation
but the point is they're they're
discriminating against a whole group
i think they are racist towards some
races the women right and it's a very
acceptable like with indian men you know
what yeah it's become a joke now how men
slide into your dms yeah but that's not
that's sexual preference
do you think do you think like you could
say the same thing with short guys it is
it is i think it is i agree with you but
for society it's racist you must sleep
with them you must like i agree with you
i agree with you but now with indian men
it's become a joke like you keep hearing
how indian men slide into yeah yeah dms
and they make fun of them and it's it is
sort of okay
but i think pearl your point is on a
higher level i think and i think it's
about the the double standard that we
have in society
that
why is it okay to be racist
when it's okay to be misandrist
and i think you mentioned it earlier you
answered your own question where
you said that men are expendable
we've been living through decades
of men being
told and women being told
that men should be disrespected in the
home men should be
their value is really nothing other than
the check
and the seed
and
men have been portrayed as bumbling
idiots
when
actually
what men do is very productive to
society and required and necessary not
just for young boys but also for girls
you know what i've noticed if you watch
ads
on tv these days the man is always the
dumbass and the woman comes to the
rescue
fixing whatever it is have you noticed
that
70 to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions are made by women so they're
always marketing to women i have an
accident i have a question for you pro
because i don't know if anybody else
notices that you may know it but
are the stats the same because nowadays
we have um
another sector of sexuality trans men
and trans women are the stats the same
if a
woman
is
know if a man is now with a trans woman
or a vice versa would those stats be the
same i i don't know okay i wasn't
interested it's probably too soon
because to me it's just like they're
still a dude you can dress like a dude
that doesn't make you
you call them [ __ ] you know it was
just accepted that there would be one
dude among a group that liked to dress
in women's clothes why is it okay to be
trans
someone asked us in the chat why is it
okay to like change your sex but you
can't change your race
i've always said this i think actually
great rachel dozer is that her name i
don't think she should be allowed like
she actually helped black people
i think change your race if you if you
want to change your race like do you
like it actually a free world it's not
that yeah i'm actually tired yeah
it's all right let me just let me let me
let me let me just okay let me just zone
in on this one
so if i if i
jesus if i really wanted to be black
yeah i could just i could just go go
tanning no it's blackface
and yeah and yeah
and
just
get i don't know and dress
i think the idea is no
she worked to help black people okay
okay let's say let's see
okay let's let's say let's say
if i the next two years i start an
orphanage in africa
i'm just asking i'm just asking then i
come back
would that win me would i could i change
my race the way i i i just no no i just
need a yes or no
of course not no
i don't actually agree with rachel's
daughters were doing that what i'm
saying
okay
so you're asking me if it's okay for you
to change your race yeah i think you can
change your race in your own little self
but don't expect me to call you black or
give you a pass to say the n word but
you just said it was okay no no no i
said i said yeah do if you want to
identify as a goddamn table be a table
for all i care just don't force me to
then put my cop on you and pretend
you're a table
i'm not going to see you
see here the thing this is the thing
right this is this is where it starts we
start by allowing people to do it in
their own and then those people get
entitled in the i you know
yeah no that's true you're right it's a
slippery slope because i mean if we told
caitlyn frickin jenner that she couldn't
have the female courage award like seven
years ago where would we be today she's
she's the world's greatest yeah thank
you very much
yes
and then and then we now we got that
freaking that dude swimming in the girls
division and taking our titles taking
the same award yeah when there's people
women who've been women their whole
lives and done things that's just how
good men are i'm sorry no i'm not even
i'm not talking about the athletics i'm
talking about the women that you are
completely disagreeing with everybody
but i actually don't disagree like i
agree with all of you but just a
different perspective
someone who's grown up in the music
business especially jazz
jazz has taught me a lot of things about
the world and culture that the rest of
the world didn't teach me
um jazz taught me that i could be black
but can i ask you a question what does
it mean to be black what okay to have
soul are you black no
but but it's so
inspiring it showed you how to be black
in america maybe but what about black
people in africa or nigeria or
you know could you explain that i need
you to explain that more
well um
there may be some people who disagree
with me but i believe that in a large
part
the american art form
as jazz of jazz
is very much a black art form it's not
only black
there there's a whole movement out there
that's pushing black american music and
trying to call jazz black american music
i disagree wholeheartedly because that
uh eliminates the latin american
influence
that eliminates all the other influences
that have made jazz what it is today but
anybody who plays jazz anybody who loves
jazz
can not
self-respectingly say that it's not a
black music
so when i play with black musicians
my biggest compliment
is when
you got the 75 year old bass player
that's in there watching you like who
the hell is this mother
who just walked up to the stage thinking
he knows what he's doing
and he you play a little bit and you
look back did i do okay and he just goes
but how does how does that
how does that make you black okay okay
that
that that's one degree of the acceptance
uh-huh over the years i've had many
musicians tell me oh yeah your honorary
black you're straight okay
okay
because now i'm not saying that
but i understand
what black music is and what makes
music that that culture i understand
where gospel comes from i understand
where slavery
led to the roots of what became jazz i
understand how pain
produces art
doesn't mean that i'm black i'm saying
that black people have over the years in
my in my business have made me feel
accepted into their community yeah and
have many times told me straight up
you're the you're the blackest brown guy
i know so that's one thing that's one
thing
i think one problem that's just that's
not me saying i'm blind
for me that's one thing that
i i haven't heard any other ethnicity
any other race say give out
freely give out like oh you're this yeah
you're black you're black you're black
and like give it out to people that's
something that frustrates me
because we there's no white car yeah we
accept like
we're so accepting as a community and
i would i would if i heard you play and
i'm like oh that that boy got so like
man he can actually play and it's like
accepting by the black community when
you
do things that are essentially from the
black community and they accept you but
we just freely oh like we got a stack of
black cards in our back pocket and we
boo everybody gets one but as soon as
someone in the black community does
something that is not black we snatch it
quick and it's so frustrating and i'm
not saying that that's uh like what you
experience is a bad thing but
i do not think that you can change your
race because it's different
from
i don't i just don't think you can
change it because there's more in it
than just your skin color or just saying
that you're from wherever you are and
just saying i'm this now it is so my
question
right is that
would you
understand that maybe
amongst the peers and the people that
you've like been around they've accepted
you and like they've they've allowed you
into their space that they may even call
sacred at some point would you
understand that
that past isn't
all the way around absolutely okay i
would never say that now i am black
because somebody black put their hand on
my shoulder
i would say that i've been accepted
by the the people who made this music
for me to come and play
i i've been
invited to the tribe
that doesn't mean that i'm black
and and for the same reason so that's
why i bring out this opposing view is to
to prove the point that anybody who
claims
to be something they're not simply
because they decide to do so
is actually disrespecting that which
they're trying to claim
because for me to call myself black
would be absolutely disrespectful to
those people that i look up to and want
their acceptance but the thing that i
find really crazy is the way everyone's
reacted so energetically to the idea of
you being black because you play the
saxophone very well
people don't have that same energy when
it comes to the original question
you know you know a man saying he's a
woman a woman saying they're mad and i
think it's interesting how slowly over
time
you know people push you know the
envelope slowly slowly slowly so when
you make acceptance of someone saying
they are i feel like i'm black so i am
black and you saying oh it's okay to
think that and then you know as long as
you don't force me to do it but that's
how it initially starts and then it
becomes and grows more into more you
know
there's now like an older gentleman
about 50 55 60 years old identifying
it's a 13 year old yep yep
i just think
have you guys ever seen the videos where
they give out n-word passes
are they pay people they're like nah nah
nah i'm not going there oh my goodness i
just think i guess that's a good
question why is it okay for some groups
of people to say racial slurs
about themselves
but not others because latinos have it
too
well with with
in
the us
okay you know the way it was explained
to me and because i don't use
i don't use the n-word you know
um
i don't think no i don't use it um but
like the way
the way growing up
the way we always talked about it's our
own locker room issue you know what i'm
saying like you're not allowed to
you know if you're not in the locker
room you're not allowed to use the word
in the context which was something i
disagreed with
but that's just based on the fact that
you know my cultural experience growing
up in the us
you know i had people
who weren't who were african-american
calling me an en wooden drug and i took
it the wrong way because looking at
seeing it on tv
growing up it didn't seem like
an appropriate word to use so it didn't
seem appropriate being said to me
you know but as i grew up in the culture
i understood the context in which it's
used i still don't use it but i
understand how so i understand why
it's a problem if
someone outside speaks
sorry to your point before um
about like you playing jazz
you know if if if i'm in the other room
and you're playing
you know and i'm like wow that that's a
good player and i didn't know what you
look like
you know but i'm like but you're a new
guy like you said you're playing with
the 75 year old or something like that
and
if i came in i was like wow you were the
one that was playing you know
that's me
you know accepting you i wouldn't think
that you were
black
but i would say oh this this guy can
play culturally that i look at in the
cultural context i like culturally okay
this guy's in like he gets the soul of
how we play and how we however it is
he's been immersed in it long enough you
know to play the way that we play it's
like you have an element of
you have an element of what our soul
like feels when we
do certain things or what is like innate
in us because to go off for your thing
there's been times where i've been in
another room and my brother's been
listening to music or i hear someone
sing and i'm like oh that girl got some
soul her voice had come out blonde hair
blue eyes i'm like oh wow i said you
must be around some black people that
taught you how to sing and it's just
something that is innate in us and you
have
you have gotten like a little a bit of
that to be able to be
not to be able to be accepted but to get
the approval of
superior musicians in that realm yeah
you've ever embodied that you've
literally embodied like
what we would feel when we hear the
sounds of
wherever we are from so yeah okay i'm
gonna take a second to read super chat
super chat um okay guys make sure you
are liking the video the like is the
most important thing that you can do to
push this video out into the algorithm
also guys after this stream we are
having a members only stream me jess and
ish are going to eat some pizza ask some
questions that you guys answer some
questions that you guys have and if you
want to just know what goes on behind
the scenes after shows um yeah
watch it it's it's going to be like a 30
40 minute live it'll be fun okay so 90
free toe pie what about eminem that
brother is black um
sentience um jazz isn't black country
isn't white give credit to its roots but
music is expressed by people of a
varying ra varying races saying jazz is
black is like saying a trans woman is a
biological woman just because you say it
doesn't make it so mr negative three
sides to every story yours mine and the
truth and the is the truth is in the
middle perception be accused as a man
you're guilty even if proven innocent
um
pearl tracks pearl ask the panel why
it's acceptable for a trans man to want
to compete in a female sport but trans
men won't even attempt to dare to join
vincent dallas aisle the super chat word
filters are annoying i can't figure out
what which word is an issue and i can't
send a good message through i don't i
don't think i put super chat filters so
i don't know
i don't know dm me if you you can tell
me how to turn them off because i i
don't even remember turning them on
um kane marco
y'all made me pull over the highway
because of this ridiculous nonsense you
all keep saying that about race which is
typical for the show there are no
honorary black cards you can't be us ata
jordan b peterson said we must be
monstrous and have it under control
man's strength is meant to protect and
provide for the family not to be a
tyrant to them vincent d'alisale jr i
have heard of trans racial on youtube
before jg 10 super chat mr negative just
wait till menopause so much to look
forward to never underestimate your
opponent he's right i'm polite and funny
but i boxed and wrestled damn where was
that math teacher when i was 13. silly
song
silly sausage i once had a girl i kicked
out of the bar
she said it was dangerous for her to be
outside i said no one is going to grape
you she got offended thinking she was
ungrateful
wow
bro
well okay i don't know
okay sentience
female is white female in the white it
is not innocent until proven guilty many
stories including a large number of men
in the chat here can tell you anecdotal
stories which show the opposite case in
point tate's recent arrest story men's
men i've never did you hear that
yeah did he have an arrest story i think
it's the whole um romanian police raid
in his um home because that girl said
well she told her boyfriend that he
forced her into trafficking did that
happen recently that was a few months
back oh i didn't even know that okay
men know the threat of other men which
is why traditionally men protected their
woman by preventing them from going out
at night fathers and brothers were
involved in courting but you're strong
and independent right
peter b it is normal for females to grab
male's parts in public
nas009 where is the boundary between
complementing flirting and harassment if
a very handsome man or not cut out
very interesting to know from the ladies
to eliminate gray areas silly sausage i
worked in security and bars for years
loads of fights started by women saying
they were graped i always checked the
security
i always checked the cameras she was
just rejected 20-man brawl almost
happened by this girl's ego
that's crazy
um alice starr horton people consider
physical damage is worse than
psychological damage that's why women
get it easy vincent dollasal what if i
fight back and then identify as a female
aquaman was talking about chrissy matt
cornstar
chase conley warm machine k mall that's
the one yeah hey jess how are you doing
you look you're looking pretty fly today
oh thank you i appreciate it
alistar horton further evidence emotion
is a weakness
sibo
nate cube if sex was abundant in society
if sex was abundant society would suck
because
keyword is is a huge motivation for us
to produce so if it was free we'd have
far less technological advancement let's
try to even think about that that's a
good point
nas009 focus always produces the best
results and focus is a direct result of
discipline thank you for the words of
wisdom sentience please don't justify
mood swings to mental illness if you are
a provider then you
know you must not only keep that
diagnosis private but also assess your
patient before the diagnosis that being
said you're just a layman and layman
should be very cautious throwing around
mental illnesses just look at what the
whole body dysmorphia craze has done
alone it's a very rare disease but now
it has grossly exploded due to people
fetish fetishizing it
alistar horton there's a way there's a
way to humble any women most women seek
an independent man by definition he
depends on no one and can do
everything he needs to do alone and what
can a woman offer him besides sex and
offspring that he can't get without her
no nothing
vincent dolizel aquaman on the left
can
awkward man on the left can just smash
them at work if his girl isn't feeling
it that day so he's all good he can't
get mad since he couldn't since she
couldn't do it
sibo and cube self-protection is a right
protection from others is a privilege
you gotta watch xqc lose it in front of
andrew tate give new meaning gives new
meaning to second-hand embarrassment
um thank you and nash09 for the sticker
eugene steele when one talks about a
right a right is related to entitlement
when one talks about a privilege a
privilege is earned or kept until it is
taken away protection is a privilege a
woman has to earn it i agree with that
vincent dallas out i can bring a whole
panel of girls easy are you in the uk
feel free to dm eddie dm eddie um oh
yeah that's the other thing if you do
want to come on the show you can dm
eddie his link is in the description
that's our recruiter um if you're in
london guys if you're not in london like
we're not we're not doing like a zoom
like this is an in-person show i can't
change it for all of you
um the almighty lord of honest honesty
last
last pink that called me
and i gutted him like a trout daniel
there's no such thing as race it's just
different skin colors davey jones 50
super chat thank you yeah let's go
the almighty lord of honesty
i dare pink say the n-word around me
ultra trek hi from poland second time on
the live stream i love your content okay
so um the next question i have
okay
oh
some of the super chats are funny they
are they are um
would you trust a female cop to stop a
sexual assault
also i want to give credit where
credit's due a lot of these questions
are from its complicated channel you
guys should go follow him
yeah yeah so a lot of these
he's very good at what he does i steal
him from him but yeah would you trust a
female cop to stop a sexual assault what
do you mean by trust
if a woman's getting sexually assaulted
would you trust a female cop to start it
so you're calling the police and they
send a woman do you trust her i mean
i'd assume that the man could overpower
her so
so now
okay
i would trust her to
try to the best of her ability to stop
it because she is a police officer and
that is her job to protect and serve and
that's why she was called to the
situation
uh
god may end up getting shot i don't see
how
you know
she just because she's in the uniform
she might be able to overpower him
you know i don't see
um
that happening
you know he probably should shoot the
guy or something but actually literally
stopping it i don't know i don't think
so
um i think yeah me answering as a female
i would feel safer even just someone
else being there because i think like
maybe with two of us we would be able to
stop him as opposed to just me on my own
so you would trust
yeah i mean i'd feel better if it was a
man but it is what it is okay
the the female officer is empowered
um has methods that uh a bystander
wouldn't be allowed to use she can use
weapons
she can call her back up
um
if she does use lethal force she has a
protector whereas a bystander wouldn't
so what i feel more protected of a woman
officer coming up to
stop my sexual assault
no
but
would she as a female officer
feel more enabled to end that sexual
assault i think so
so if i was a woman however i i agree
with you 100 just having the other
person there makes that assaulter kind
of freak out
would he stop
could that woman stop him i don't know
but maybe she had her weapons maybe
but the bystander no so i think the
female cop
yes could stop it but um females in
general i don't think would be able to
i think it would like um because it
comes down to also skill
and if she has a weapon as well like i
hope she has a gun
uh but if you ask me
i'm hanging from a cliff
and there's a man and a woman
who would have picked to lift me up it
would obviously be a man when it comes
to power yeah i would trust a man
but because of skill and training
yeah i wouldn't really have a problem
yeah but the thing is
like police officers don't have guns and
stuff so like if it was happening here
wouldn't you just rather i don't ever
know what happens here oh yeah oh yeah
uk and police officers don't have guns
yeah definitely a man yeah that's what
it just hit me i was thinking about nypd
is the question pertaining to
a woman being sexually assaulted or if
it was
at the
the individual in general
if a woman's being sexually assaulted i
feel so what about if it was a man is
that not relevant to what you're i'm i
mean the the perpetrator is a man in
both scenarios
i mean if he's able to overpower me if
the guy's able to found me i'd assume
he'd be able to also overpower the
female so
why are men expected to be protectors if
it is said that women are just as
capable
um
you know because it's their duty
if you're not my mum my sister my girl
significant other
a friend
i will not protect you like i'm sorry
like i don't know what you've done i
don't know who you've you know
that shows
chat shows
i consider posting
but what i was saying is if i just see
someone on the street arguing with their
boyfriend and he happens to ha i'm sorry
i'm walking away yeah i'll call the
police for you
i'm walking away
okay so
this happened like a year ago
i was
indulged in i'm going through like the
thing
this this guy this tall guy like walks
up on this woman you could see from her
face she was like terrified
didn't know it from eve but like i just
walked up to her and i said
you know not looking at the guy i said
um are you ready let's go
you know are you all right
you know and the guy just looked at me
and i could see he was gazing and he
just walked away
so and then when she walked away i just
said oh you're all right and i just and
she like nodded and i just turned away
so
i understand what you're saying you like
don't want to get you
you don't want to get tangled up in it
but at the same time like the kind of
dude i'm i'd still be walking away like
yo okay but what if what if that was her
boyfriend right and you ended up getting
in the fight with him going to prison
and then she goes back to him afterwards
wouldn't you feel like a [ __ ]
i'm sorry i'm not i'm not putting my
life on the line or
extremely that happens oh no that
happens all the time
it happens so many times man and it's
like why should i put my life on the
line
for a situation i don't even know the
ins and outs of
yeah i mean
i definitely understand that part
um i have a question what if she's
getting graped
grapes is a bit different okay because
no matter what's happening that's wrong
you know so yeah
no matter what's happening that's always
wrong so i would intervene but if it's
just someone getting in the fight i'm
calling the police like okay let me ask
you anything what if it was like a
massive dude
raping excuse me creating this girl
i'd still try to do something
accordingly still but i'd still try to
do something that's completely different
it's always i think it's always wrong
yeah you know i've done obviously it's
wrong
it comes down to like your safety as
well yeah of course but that's i think
it's a bit different in that situation i
gotta say
when when you're seeing it happen yeah
there's as well
the judgment call comes in a little
different to what like in reality about
what we might classes are actually for
those men to protect i think like the
first thing
that's gonna say yeah
that's why i think girls get away with a
lot of stuff too because they know that
they know if they they act a certain way
in public men will come to their rescue
because
you see them in court crying and stuff
because like our default is like oh
protect she's crying she's hurt you know
how many times you've seen a video
doing something to a guy and then her
boyfriend having to bear the
repercussions of her doing that thing to
the guy so yeah you know woman starting
on the man and then that man punching
her boyfriend up can i i think that's
starting to reverse though now i i've
experienced it personally um i used to
open the door for every woman
young or old
and uh so many times have i had to say
thank you for them
and i'll say it loud
oh you're welcome
you know and and what i'm walking away
thinking is like you know what that's
the last time i ever opened a door for a
woman seriously
and and i've i i'm ashamed to say that i
saw it because it changed me
in the negative i think that's something
i should do for everyone i was taught
that that's what you do for a woman i
believe that's wrong i think that's
something you do for everyone
but i see that the chivalry that a lot
of women like to see in guys
is kind of disappearing
i think it should and because we don't
appreciate you know whether it's sure it
shouldn't i think we're in a state where
one group of us wants it the other group
of us wants to do it but doesn't see the
point and actually gets a lot of crap
you know what i've noticed so we're just
kind of like at this point we're like
you know i would rather just
you do you even if you're in the corner
and you're getting hurt i'm gonna go
over here because i'm not interested in
the consequences of that you know what
i've noticed is that when women say
they're romantic they mean they want the
man to be romantic and romantic it's not
themselves like they would never buy
flowers they want the guy to buy flowers
for them that's what romance is to them
can i ask something that's true
that's very that's like
at least of of modern women it's maybe
the older generations women used to do
things for the guys in other ways but i
think yeah because then men were the
price though exactly oh i have a
question for the girls what's the most
romantic thing you've done for a guy
good one
um so i've done like um
a rooftop sort of picnic thing um for
my well then he was my boyfriend so
um went shopping got all the food he
liked and just
had that romantic setting for him and he
really appreciated it do you think
that's something that you would have
wanted or something he would have wanted
nice one
um
i'm just i don't know your man in it
is that something you would have wanted
or he would have wanted
or did he just appreciate it i i think i
think he really liked it he even called
family and zoom cool and it was like
look what she did
but i guess what he's saying
from did you do for him what you wanted
him to do for you or did you actually
think like this is what that man
wants
yeah do you think that men walk around
thinking oh you know what i really want
a romantic rooftop thing yeah because
would love that i would love it but i
know what you're talking about we would
probably like to watch die hard by
ourselves that would be romantic for us
before you carry on
what you did
was wonderful no it was yeah we don't
want to take away from what you've done
we're just trying to yeah yeah
yeah from the perspective of a man like
if i
for example i i just came back from
scotland i had a beautiful visit with a
woman that i adore
she's if i was to marry a woman this
would be exactly the type and she's old
school she takes care of her man
and one of the things that she did for
me when i arrived
is she she had a suit waiting for me
and she put that suit on me
she made me dinner that night
we went out we went to a jazz club over
in scotland i went up on stage she sat
there and chilled and waited for me and
when i was done and everybody was done
talking to me she just sat there and she
waited for me
that was
what women would consider romantic from
a guy's perspective i don't think that's
really romantic from a woman's
perspective but if you want my heart
that's that's how you get it because she
did everything that i just wish every
woman would do for me i see your point i
think maybe if the question was asked to
my fiance maybe he might come up with a
different example of something else i've
done but because the question relaxed to
me
i would say that's probably the most
romantic thing so i'm going to frame it
i can't frame it as a man i would love
if someone did that for me oh my god but
general men are romantic for themselves
i mean
it's different what about you jess
my mind's just blown right now because
um
what i did i would say probably one of
the
most romantic things was similar to you
but was for his birthday i liked
balloons happy birthday and it was a
surprise he didn't know that it was
happening and got him some of his
favorite stuff
um
bought some things that he needed and
just like a little goodie bag and then i
surprised him confetti everything
balloons the whole nine
and from hearing what you guys are
saying
that's something that i would want
someone to do for me like surprisingly
like hey babe like your birthday
dissenter and i'm like no no it's not
like that but
what
like to understand like how men think
what is like
something that
so say for your birthday what is
something that you would want a woman to
do for you that is romantic and immansen
and manson not in a woman's for me
personally for me personally all i need
for my goal is to you know
put on some animes that i watch and
order some pizza and we watch it
together and i'll be calm
like i wouldn't need much more than that
buy me ps5 if you want what would be
what what would be above and beyond so
buying you a ps5 you're buying buy me a
ps5 taking me abroad like anything like
that oh you want to be you want to be
taken out yeah
where do you want her to take you like
maybe there could be some girls in the
chat watching i'm a married mother
without a ring look at it look at it fly
him out
what i'm saying is it's like it's the
little things you know if you're showing
interest in the things that i have
interested in then that's that's all i'd
need like i wouldn't need anything extra
to me the best thing is like where they
listen to you so you said something at
some point oh i really want to read this
book whatever because that's what my ex
did she was in sweden i was in australia
i told her once ages ago i really want
to read this book sapiens i don't know
if you read it great book
i wake up one day i have a delivery it's
that book why is ux
yesterday
no that because when i was when i was
with my ex-boyfriend i bought him like a
phone wall at once and it was just
because he like mentioned he like needed
it but it was i didn't understand why i
was such a big he was like
that was so nice
and i was like it's just like it was
like five bucks i just saw it at the
store
you know they like to go window shopping
because they like the act
men purchase things because of a need
that needs to be satisfied that's when
we go shopping we go on a mission to be
accomplished as quickly as possible
women like to extend the time as much as
possible because it's the act
that okay maybe i'll disagree this is
just my oh no for me personally
we were raised like boys yes that's
right
i'm a boy on the inside i was speaking
very i agree with you yeah yeah yeah but
guys when when so like you bought that
wallet right that was a need that was
satisfied that's huge for a man to have
a problem solved
that's like that's huge because our
stress is relieved right i don't agree
with you i think we like solving the
problem ourselves
okay i get you it's like a masculine
thing yeah yeah we all want to solve the
problem ourselves
if our woman was to do something like
that like let's say um let's say you had
shoes and you just you you just wore
those shoes they started to have holes
i'm not going to get rid of them until
they fall apart and then one day your
woman gets you some brand new shoes at
first you're going to be like
man i was going to wear these until the
end and you're a little irritated with
her and then like a couple days later
you put them on and you're like man
these are kind of
he always used to have holes in his
shoes growing up he's like the most
successful man i know he has holes in
his shoes
my mother would do the same thing she
would buy me shirts when i told her like
i don't need it i don't need if i if i
need if i if it's something i needed i'm
gonna buy it
obviously i would appreciate it
but i didn't i wanted to satisfy my own
need you know what i mean as a man it's
like a masculine i understand what
you're saying i understand something but
so like for me when i work from home i
tend to not eat um because i'll just be
so you know
focused on my work i'll just i wouldn't
be able to go downstairs and make food
or or i would be able to but i'll just
forget sometimes my girl coming up and
bringing me food would be like i could
have done that myself but i'll
appreciate that of course that's that's
like another level of like what if the
food's trash
just because your chicken is dry
even if the food is is trash
yeah like it up if you want to see
pearl's chicken
you might not want to see it
just where's my chicken dry no yeah just
wait i'm not lying and she sees this in
it come on she sees it she paint you was
saying come on there it is
oh my god the audacity of
wings
look at my my wings are fire
you've never anyways
okay i'll bring the hot sauce oh yeah no
i got hot sauce
yeah okay
okay um next question so
if a woman and a man are attacked in
public who is more likely to be rescued
the woman i already know the answer
hands down
well men i don't you the way your
questions are framed even the last one
i'm like but are men actually fully
desiring for women to protect them or
for someone to come and rescue them like
it's not it you get what you demand let
me ask the second part of the question
why are women afraid to be out in public
when they are more likely to be rescued
i think they can't help but they're
still afraid it's just like a feeling
they have really cause i just think
they're delusional
are women afraid to be out in public
there's a lot of double standards jesse
jesse when i was interviewing people
were women afraid to be out in public
they said they were yeah where were they
in their house
right you're talking to women in the
united kingdom
the united kingdom has a queen not a
king
but a queen this is a matriarchy by
definition
so any woman in the united kingdom that
complains about the patriarchy is
obviously delusional
however
this mentality is all over the world
so even in the united states women
complain about a patriarchy
we live in a world where women have an
advantage over men in basically every
aspect
women will
generally
have more benefits
we talk about the pay gap
like women make less than men but they
actually get way more benefits than men
get because men don't have
repro uh
what is that
you know
birth control we don't have anything
like that offered to us we don't have
paternity leave
we don't have
uh the right to be able to brought back
to our jobs after our woman has a baby
we don't have any of those sorts of
things
so
there's a lot of delusion going on so
when we're when when women go out
thinking that they're always in danger
yeah that you you want people to be
aware of the dangers but i think yeah
there's a lot of people out there
many of the women have this idea that
yeah
i can
play the victim
and still be aggressive
and i think that's i want to talk about
the pay gap actually
we should come back to that the pay gap
do you mean that myth
yeah
do you guys believe there's some some
back and forth to it but i'm curious i
don't know though because i mean look
men take more dangerous jobs obviously
we're going to get paid for more for
that
that's the one with the bond and your
realm of work women get paid more don't
they
uh only found some carpentry because i
don't think there's any only fans yeah
look exactly how are you gonna
porn in general not just not just corn
excuse me in general not just only fans
mm-hmm
yeah where's the pig gap there where is
the justice there but it's interesting
you won't hear any woman complaining
about that because it suits you exactly
yeah yeah
i've met women who are electricians um
in my entire life i've worked on cruise
ships since
2000 1999.
and in my entire career i've met one
female electrician
i've met
three female engineers
um
and
all of them were gorgeous don't get me
wrong one of them was a lesbian
but all of them
and
one of the lesbian i wasn't even really
sure
but the point being is that they're out
there they will get the job and they'll
tell you about how difficult it is to be
a woman in a man's world
fine
but i don't see
lines of women
studying to be journeymen i don't see it
mm-hmm
it couldn't be me no no they don't want
to complain that they're getting paid
less well yeah we're doing a different
job we're doing something more dangerous
yeah but even take it in
in a in a job where let's just say it's
an office job and you got a man and
woman sitting next to each other in a
cubicle
that woman may have a smaller salary
but that doesn't mean she's getting paid
less
because when she goes on maternity leave
she's still getting paid for not doing
the work that man is still there working
every day but even even let's say let's
say that this actually happened right
let's say that you got was real
logically it would make no sense because
why would i hire a man if i can hire a
woman pay her less
and she does just as good just as good
or even or even better job it doesn't
make sense for me as a business
more women but people don't think about
that when they're talking about these
things it's like
logically it makes no sense for a
business whose whole purpose is to make
a profit to do that when it you know one
of the largest expenses of business has
is wages
that's cherry picking to take one small
little detail or or red herring they
call it take a small little detail and
inflate that and make that oh this is
this is the main point when it actually
doesn't really tell the whole story what
gets me is that they're complaining
about it so like if they were getting
paid less
then why wouldn't companies hire them
and do the same
do the same job
they either you're not doing the same
job or
who knows so i had an incident where um
sorry go ahead go god i didn't when i
used to work at a bank in new york and
um you know this co-worker she didn't
like direct deposit so i had to
physically cash a check and you know i
split you know you split the thing and i
could see her hourly rate i was a
supervisor and
she made more money than me
you know so like when when
and she was a
part-timer and to put this into context
in i think i was there like seven years
she had like two kids
the first kid she had she went on
maternity within the first year so she
was out
even though she was working
or an employee and she came back and she
got pregnant so
when i first started to read about the
whole pay gap thing
my mind always goes back to that because
i'm thinking okay she was a part-timer
and she was making like almost
you know two to almost three bucks an
hour more than hours
so how is it how where's this payback
thing and not to you know one of the
things i told myself is like okay don't
make this a rule this could be an
exception it's
it's possible i have no way of knowing
but
you know when whenever this debate comes
up that's what i always think about
because i'm like somewhere there's
someone who's getting shorted one in the
in the other direction no matter what we
think about um
the pay gap issue that men are getting
paid more
for you know for whatever reason you
know i just i think there's there's a
lot there
you know that isn't talked about enough
or we haven't seen yeah it's like you
said as well like there's plenty of jobs
that
i it's harder for men to get higher like
only fans and corn and modeling as well
because i model it's so much harder for
me to get
modelling gigs and women just you know
so easy of them so double standards
so next question okay
what is a better form this is going to
be interesting because we're in the uk
what is a better form of protection
owning a gun or calling the police
[Music]
depending on what area you're in
okay
so if someone's trying to stab me what's
quicker
oh i'm i was thinking the context was
like you're at home but
i got you
i'm pretty fast i can't run away
you are pretty fast
wait wait wait are you fast now
i think i'm passing you i'm kidding
not right now give me a few months okay
so you said gun you said depends okay
yes
if it's just me i'd rather um police but
if i have my family i'd rather have a
gun okay which which ones you didn't
answer the question one or the other
i'm going i'll say okay
yeah pick one
is it mean the situation it doesn't
what's a better form of protection for
anyone a gun or calling the police
uh
i'm gonna say call in the police
okay so let me just i don't want guns in
this country just let me let me just get
this straight let me just take this
straight i'm about to get stabbed okay
and i have guns here i'm about to get
stabbed i call the police where i shoot
him what's quicker
yeah but i don't want to kill someone
that's like just human
i mean you don't have to your house
i think we've got lesser to evil i think
i'm going to be scarred by that i just i
don't know
i'll just die
okay go ahead what do you think and and
to build off of your point you probably
will be scarred if you don't know how to
use that gun
then you're gonna probably kill yourself
that's not the question
so i mean you know how to use it
assuming that you know how to use it yes
i'd absolutely go for the guy if i don't
know how to use it
okay good
which one um
gone gun okay
why are why are men expected to be
protectors when women are just as
capable of firing a gun or calling the
police
um well because not everyone has a gun i
guess that you still feel everyone's got
a cell phone but
um i think that's some modern
convenience so
throughout history like you know you go
back 2000 years ago they didn't really
have police like that yeah they didn't
have phones to call police and they
didn't have um guns so
in those times we didn't expect it for
the man to take care of his wife take
care of his children take care of his
family yeah plus right it's something
we've been conditioned to do i think and
it's been passed on throughout all
generations even now when people are
saying that they don't want toxic men is
it is it outdated in 2022 i don't think
it's necessarily outdated because i
would want to be able to i would think
that i'd want to protect as a man i'd
want to protect my family and you know
any man who doesn't
it's peak for you guys your wife's going
to leave you at some point
but you know
i i think
it just goes back to how
um
reality doesn't adhere to social norms
it doesn't necessarily adhere to social
norms so you might say that as a woman
you know you're equal to me and you know
you're just as capable in things as me
but then let's be honest it's biological
differences i might be more calm within
that situation than you you would be
because your hormones are different to
mine
and so it makes more sense for me to you
know be the protector and be the one
trying to
sort things out what about you
[Music]
ask the question again why are men
expected to be protectors when women are
just as capable of firing a gun or
calling the police
i i don't know why men are expected i
guess because
it's just a thing that
is innate in them to be protected but
like you said women are capable of doing
that but a lot of women
a lot of women don't
want to and
they assume the man's going to do it
anyways so
they don't
they just don't
if that answers the question
okay go ahead what do you guys think
[Music]
uh well
at the end of at the end of the day it's
whatever is the best option
that keeps everybody safe
so
i think that's you know that's what you
go with
if
my ladies in the home you know i'm gonna
be like if someone breaks in do this
you know i'm saying if
if
she's the one
if she's gonna be by herself that's what
i would that's how i would listen
someone could break in if you're worried
this is what you do this is the plan
stick with that until authorities get
here or whatever or till i get here
you know what i'm saying so
yeah i just think like roles in
relationships are important so i feel
like
even though like me as a woman i can
protect myself technically um but at the
same time i feel like if i always had to
be this woman oh i'm protecting myself
it i would kind of just lose my
femininity so i feel like that is
something that
for whatever reason it's been more
assigned to to men it's more of a
masculine trait and i feel like
that's something that's missing in our
society like men are no longer masculine
and so i don't think it's helpful for us
to take away
things that make them
more masculine things that make women
more feminine
okay
i guess it's the difference between
capable
of and should
i think the whole feminist
argument as a whole
is about proving that women are capable
of doing something
that men can do
the question is should they
should women be the lead in the
household should women
be the breadwinners should women be the
protectors
are they capable of it yeah that woman's
absolutely capable of pulling that
trigger
but in that household
with a man there should she
if she's by herself absolutely i want
i'm going to take my daughter to
california and i'm going to take her to
a gun range someday i want to teach her
how to shoot a gun
when she's here i'm going to teach her
to us respect the laws
but she's going to be able to
however do i want her to be in a
position to where she has to make that
choice no i want her to have a happy
family and a man that's going to protect
her
so she never has to make that decision
so i guess it i mean i i don't know if
it properly answers your question but i
i think it's it's really a question of
you know feminism has
made women think
that because they are capable of doing
something that they should do you think
most women want to
no
i think they want to be protected and
they've been told
that they should be the protector which
is against their nature
yeah i agree i think they just keep
society keeps telling them like you
should not you should be capable you
should be you should be capable you
should be able to protect yourself but
it's gonna turn you off
if
something happens someone brings it to
your house and your man doesn't protect
you you keep hearing like i want a
feminine man i know someone who's
in touch with the feminine side and all
that but i don't think so when that
happens you would want what is called a
toxic man these days some toxic
masculinity whatever you want to call it
um yeah i think would turn you off if if
that was the case but
you should be able to protect yourself
can i just say that if any woman that
talks about toxic masculinity or
menotrash and menadis man of that if you
think i'll protect you when there's
something's going on
you are by yourself are you saying are
you saying that you wouldn't have
protected the whales um why would i
why would you get did you get a t-shirt
by the way
shave the world it's coming soon let's
go and see dory yeah
one of my only fans i get a lot of what
they call themselves feminist and
they're like oh i like being in control
and whatever but because there is a
fantasy that would tell me like i'm a
feminist i support women's rights blah
blah blah
but
in their fantasy that they ask me for
like voice notes and whatever they
always want to be dominated
that goes out the window when when they
need to you know get off it's true sure
yeah i think i've said this before on
the show but
there's a reddit thread of girls being
turned on by the handmaid's tale yeah i
started watching it up to you yeah
they're literally it's a show where
basically the world is infertile except
for a couple like like there's a small
minority of women that are still fertile
and they basically sell those women to
like rich
families and the dude they'll be like
held down and graped once a month when
their peak ovulation so that's why
whenever there's a abortion law that's
passed everyone's like we're going to
the handmaid's tale
and uh yeah and so there was a whole
reddit thread where they're talking
about how turned on they were
and women and women are the most the
ones that watch it
i mean you feel you have to like a
little bit if you're watching you know
even um i don't know if you remember
that film came out drink over like 365
days or something yeah so cringe oh my
days there was this one girl
i don't know you like me i haven't seen
that there's this one clip of this guy
he's like there's some italian i think
italian mafia sort of person right
and um the lady's in the shower and he
grabs her by her throat and all these
obviously obviously that would be seen
if any man did that in real life that
would be seen as okay this is cut this
is basically so no you will see it's
very attractive but yeah people in their
stories people in the stories or on
instagram were saying oh why can't a guy
just do this to me that's right
uh-huh okay okay then
um i'm gonna read super chats um and
then after i'm done i think we're gonna
do like final thoughts and close out the
show so
um let's start with ata
get touched by evil wait get touched by
evil your perspective will change throw
guns a gun is an equalizer for a woman
versus a massive man with evil intent 90
free toe pie when you ask these
questions have them repeat it back matt
butcher in arizona lots of carry open
and concealed lots carry open and
concealed not saying women don't get
stupid anyway not saying people don't
get stupid anyway but it helps keep the
stupid level down
marlon brando every time a female has
done something romantic for me it's
something she wanted and never anything
i wanted um
pearl
[Music]
sibo and cube pearl has been with tyrone
you know her chickens got to be on point
by now peter peter quaid um you should
try you should try pearl's fire boiled
chicken recipe 90 stop laughing stop it
90 free toe pie women um are kanye
well i can't read this 90 free to buy
women are commie
ugly but want pretty privileged men are
capitalists sol you're on your own women
romance
women's romance is about them it's all
about them everything shawn jackson i
don't want romance i do that because
that's what my current wife wants and
most of the women i've dated have wanted
i personally don't care about romance
myself doug mpa women don't spend
anything on men um
two did the guy get laid after the
picnic date if he didn't it didn't count
three
three jess is the best matt butcher
feminism killed chivalry a lot more this
is why we can't have nice things play
stupid games win stupid prizes ata
massive if if it's a massive green dude
if if it's a massive dude graping i'd
walk away he might find me cute davey
davey jones i would trust a female cop
to do what most men cops male cops do
panic under pressure and make the wrong
decision alistar horton you say if
you're not in london what if they're
willing to travel
again if you're willing to travel
yeah you can come on but it's best if
you're a guy it's hard to get on the
show there's a lot of guys that want to
come on so i would just say the best way
to get on is to have females that you
can bring
90 frito pie
and patrice o'neill had a false grape
accusation the almighty lord of honesty
last oh pink lady oh i should've read
this one um okay
so also guys after the stream we're
doing a um a live stream for the members
it's gonna be a lot of fun it's our
first one so yeah
just just put a lot of work into like
planning it so shout out jess
um so if you guys want to be a part of
that sign up for our memberships but
we're gonna go around first and do final
thoughts so go ahead jess uh final
thoughts as i said in the beginning um
if you're not my mum my sister a friend
uh my significant other
you're not getting any protection from
me so don't don't act stupid um but yeah
guys follow me on um
tik tok and instagram not instagram uh
youtube um jessepro's
uh if you want to see paul get attacked
by will that's where we see the video so
yeah they took it off my channel so i'll
go watch it on hers
um final thoughts uh just be
be aware don't be fearful because then
you won't
you won't enjoy life be aware of your
surroundings be aware of the people
around you and use common sense when it
comes to
just situations
um you can find me on instagram and
youtube uh youtube is it's your girl
chess and instagram it's it's ya dot
girl underscore jess
i see what you're trying to change
because pearl's like it's too long bruh
it is
who's gonna
people still type it in and find me so i
think it's perfectly fine
you do i mean you got it like that you
gotta why give him an extra barrier
if they want to find me they'll find me
oh god yeah um i just think you should
be
accountable for your decisions
you know
yeah you should have fun and live your
life and all that but don't put yourself
in
crazy situations where you're wondering
like how did i get here so
you know
i think as long as you make those like
sort of somewhat sound decisions and
have like the right people around you
that's another thing
so you know less likely that you'll be
afraid of what might happen or what's
going on
um that's it um my instagram is
niger underscore nuts
cool yeah i just think um a lot of
what's going on in society right now is
is super super crazy but
then the tendency with that is to try
and like over correct things so to say
oh why should men protect and all of
that and i also think that also feeds
into the problem so the only way we can
sort of fix the problem is stand firm in
um whatever it is that we believe in and
so that that's my final thoughts
well i think uh for all the ladies who
have been wondering where all the good
guys um why can't i get what i want from
the guys that i want
i can tell you very simply
if you want a guy's attention you want
to keep it you want a guy to do things
for you including protect you and
provide for you
um and make you have that
feed him
take care of his children take care of
his home
make him feel like he's the only man in
the world
and you'll never have to worry about him
coming home
it's like that old saying that i
mentioned earlier belly full something
else empty
it's very simple men are simple just you
know take care of us and we'll take care
of you but don't expect one without the
other
uh final thoughts uh what i'm realizing
is that there's more and more double
standards and that's actually kind of
okay
i think we should have some roles i
think men are happy
to for example be providers and
protectors and women are happy to be
submissive for example
and now lately it seems like we're
having a problem with that because women
are trying to find an identity because
trying to become more
masculine and they are miserable because
of that and same with men you keep
hearing oh i want a feminine man i want
men to be more in touch with their
emotions
men don't want that i mean women don't
want that on a man either
so it's okay to have double standards
it's okay to have roles
that's it
social media
tick tock and instagram is
dot sick l i dot sick and uh
if you want more
subscribe to my only fans
[Music]
okay guys i'm just gonna go through the
announcements one more time
subscribe to our clips channel i think
we should get to 20k subs by the end of
the week that's my goal this week so hit
the subscribe button on the clips
channel the good thing about the clips
channel is if you don't want to be
notified you know some people
the ninja watchers i see you guys um on
here that don't subscribe here if you
don't want to be
notified every time that we're live you
can at least do this clips channel and
subscribe there um also we're having our
members only live show after this you
guys can
ask some questions in the chat you know
um it'll be a lot of fun there's also a
new tier of um memberships where you can
have a one-on-one call with me once a
month so if you guys are interested
that's our fourth tier
like the video that is the most
important metric i'd really like to get
to 2 000 likes there's 2 000 people in
here for most of the stream so like the
video
all of the donations today are going
towards a new studio which
is they're they're nice right y'all
going to be surprised by the new update
it's it's going to be really cool but
the more um donations and that sort of
thing that we can count on the better
studio everything that you guys give me
i literally just reinvest back into the
channel so
i'm really appreciative to everyone that
donated today and you know that donates
um every time who's our member of the
week jess our member of the week is
sentience
eddie if you want to go on the show um
if you're in london especially if you
got girls you can bring i know i've said
this so many times but sometimes we're
low on girls so
so um okay guys like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel ring
that notification bell and we will talk
to you next time
well done everybody thank you that
definitely went a lot more peaceful than
my first time
i know i recognized you yeah like you
you didn't recognize you did you was he
had a different hair
at first but the more you were here i
was like oh no she's fun too
to